Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to the ADHD quiz.
Now this quiz is legitimate because it comes from a website called:
Totally ADD. So you know they take it seriously here and whatever this answer says means that I have
gratuitous amounts of ADDDHADHH...
ADHD? I actually DO have ADD. I take medication for it, and I am very forgetful when I'm not on it,
but I've never taken a test like this before.
I've taken a legitimate, like, test, and I've been tested for hours and hours
and I did that, but th-that's all BULLSHIT! Who cares what they say those are doctors,
THIS is the INTERNET! These are the people that I trust! So let's see...
"What are the signs?" For those of you don't know what ADHD is, is "It's ongoing and,"
"impairing when inattention procrastination overwhelm and restlessness are constant"
"frustrating problems that undermine many areas of your life..."
It's a disorder...
This quiz has been approved by two independent ADHD specialists."
T W O.
"It will give you a sense of whether or not you have this 'mindset' But will not replace a proper assessment." WELL BULLSHIT TO THAT. Let's take it...
I UNDERSTAND! "There are 18 quick questions. First explore 9 in 'Inattention and Focus.' Of course life is rarely black and white. If what we are"
describing happens to you regularly then say YES."
It's select NO if it's 'hardly ever' or 'not at all' ALRIGHT. "Poor Attention to Detail..."
"I often make small mistakes in my work."
"I skim read, I tend to rush things."
"I mess up dates, get numbers wrong, or fail to notic-notice typos. I often overlook details in filling out forms, forget to add attachments to emails."
Yeah, pretty much.
I forget shit all the time, but that doesn't MEAN anything.
"I'm easily distracted."
"I find it difficult to stick the longer tasks even leisure activities."
"I may go off to do something else or I end up doing things several times at once."
"I struggle to fall through on complex tasks, short deadlines work best for me."
YEAH, PRETTY MUCH, that it annoys all my friends because I never ever stick to what I say I was going to do. BUT eyy...
You know it doesn't mean...
"Poor Listener. I find I'm easily distracted during long conversations."
"I tend to tune out, I may be looking right at someone, but I'm lost in thought, my mind often wanders."
WELL, OKAY.
But who doesn't that apply to!?
These are like general -- like -- horoscope questions!
"Don't Follow Instructions.
"I prefer to JUMP right in rather than rather read through instructions guides or reciPES. I don't have regular routines at work or home."
"I struggle with schedules or plans."
"I'm not being obstinate. I know what to do,"
I just can't seem to do it"
Ahhhh yeah. I every single Ikea furniture package. I've ever opened,
I never look at the instructions until it's too late!
"I feel disorganized."
God. Do not look at my
Apartment right now do not look into the Chaos of my life!
"I create long to-do lists and then find them overwhelming planning a big project feels daunting."
"I procrastinate because I can't see where to start to figure out what I need."
Well, yeah, but now I feel bad cuz I've been answering this ever-
I mean, I know I have it!
But it doesn't need to prove its so succinctly!
"I avoid tasks that require sustained mental effort."
"I struggle to finish things that demand a lot of focus for a long period of time."
"Other times I get 'in the zone' and hyper focus."
"I avoid routine tasks that feel monotonous repetitive or boring."
'When faced with a big, important task, I will do a bunch of trivial chores instead."
"I hate paperwork."
Now, see this is where I can actually say no. I love a project that is
Monotonous to all hell. Like, digging a hole in Minecraft or working on a big ass compilation like I like doing that
It's only starting it.
It's only starting that gets me a problem, but once I'm in I am in I am laser focused!
I love that, so I'm gonna say no.
"OFTEN LOSE THINGS I NEED."
Oh, God.
Once again in the mess of my apartment. Don't look over there, but it's a goddamn mess.
Everything is Chaos. Yeah.
"I'm easily distracted by conversation noises or activities happening around me."
"I'm easily lost in thought, my mind will be far away, imagining ideas, interesting ideas, situations, or conversations."
"I'm pretty smart, but a bit absentminded
"I've been called a daydreamer."
Oh, yeah, write-up complimenting of my own ass about. How smart. I am well. Yes
I'm a genius.
But yeah, distracted.
"FORGETFUL"
"I often lose track of what I'm supposed to be doing or pretty done."
Oh, God,
I'm the worst I'm so forgetful!
Unbelievably yeah, that's me alright
So that was the first half how'd I do? "Your total is 8 out of 9. A score of 5 or higher suggests:"
"Inattention is a problem for you. While most people struggle with some of these symptoms that doesn't mean they have ADHD."
"They could be stressed by Major life events or any number of medical issues."
Doesn't have to be anything we're going to look at hyperactivity next. Now,
I don't think I don't think I have hyperactivity because I I believe I was diagnosed with ADD not ADHD.
We shall see got a part two.
"You probably don't bounce around like a hyperactive child,"
"But perhaps you feel often restless driven like there's a dynamo inside of you."
"Maybe you're impatient. On the go. Thoughts race, sometimes tumbling, ricocheting as you pour out one idea after another."
"You may crave excitement of trying new things or love highly stimulating activities with a big payoff."
Hell yeah, oh f*ck yeah, that sounds awesome.
"PHISICALLY RESTLESS. FIDGETY."
"I grow fidgety during meetings classes and church I can become angst- ANSTY and feed during long conversations."
"I fidget with keys, bracelet, coins, pens. Twirl my hair. Doodle. These things help me focus and listen."
Actually, no, I've never been one to do this.
I've never been one of the foot tapper like, things like that repetitive things and just like,
ansty nature has never been like, I am the most patient guy in the world
So I've actually no, on this one.
"I FEEL THE NEED TO GET UP AND MOVE."
This one is me because when I'm watching a movie, or anything like that,
I have to be
Standing. Like, everyone else in the room can be sitting but I have to be standing and pacing around like I just I have to do that.
"RESTLESS."
"I'm impatient or agitated when things are quiet."
"I feel rushed, pressured, or driven even doing something that isn't urgent."
"I have frequent job changes and move frequently."
YEP I do I say in my new apartment!
"DIFFICULTY ENJOYING LEISURE ACTIVITIES QUIETLY."
"I find it hard to relax or work quietly. Small talk is boring."
"I always have to be trying new things or changing them up. I'm always pushing the envelope tweaking and adjusting."
God
I am- my life- the reason why my background and my lighting setup changes so much is because I fiddle with it, ALL THE TIME!
Everyone gets on my case about it. I am a fiddler.
I love fiddling.
Ah, "I can be over the top center of attention. So what they have a bit immature prone to drama."
Everything's  a big deal with me." Hey!
N-no!
Alright, "It always seems like I'm on the go, driven by a motor."
"I'm drawn to one hobby or obsession after another. I have more stamina and,"
"enthusiasm than anyone else if it's something I find interesting."
"I dive in whole hog, like a whirling dervish with tons of energy, but then suddenly crash. I'm more of a sprinter than a marathoner."
Yeah, that's me. I dive in so hard, like the last time I got completely obsessed with something,
I started a YouTube channel. And now  I'm feeling the same way about music, and I'm not
I'm being very hesitant about it.
"NOT RUDE. BUT TALKATIVE."
"I always have lots to say, but I'm not so great at listening."
"I can be an enthusiastic
chatterbox who can't stop. If someone else tries to speak I get louder because I feel pressure to get it out. I tend to dominate
conversations, telling great stories, but rarely learning anything about anyone else. I always have to top or match someone else's story."
Now see, you may think that I would say yes to this, but actually in personal conversation. I am the opposite, I love listening.
I love engaging in conversation, but I have a great mind to SHARE and not just dominate the conversation like I'm a good speaker,
I am, I'm a great public speaker, and I love the sound of my own voice.
But don't get me wrong, in a normal one-to-one conversation like I'll listen more than I'll say so no.
"Blurting out."
"I'm full of ideas, my mind jumps ahead and races."
"I don't sit quietly and consider."
"But immediately offer one idea or opinion after another."
"I may seem impatient or dominating, always adding my two cents, having to"
"contribute my ideas and I have lots of them."
"I'm instantly enthusiastic and interested in new challenges,"
"I say yes to everything and then end up overwhelmed with commitments."
Now,  I'm like half on this one,
I'm not one to just blurt out EVERY idea in my mind in certain sessions like brainstorming sessions,
you need that, but I'm actually RESERVED until I have an idea that, that I think is decent.
Maybe not good, but decent, so I'm going to say no.
"WAITING MY TURN IS FRUSTRATING"
"I hate lineups. Or waiting for other people to arrive.
"I will move from one checkout line to another seeking the fastest cashier."
Who doesn't do that?!
"l will go out of my way to avoid slow traffic."
Well, okay!
"Or long conversations. I can't stand people who speak slowly."
"Small talk is painfully boring."
"A friend who asked the waitress step out every item on the menu makes me go crazy."
"Hate waiting for other people to arrive I can't just sit back and relax."
Well. This is like an everybody question who wouldn't answer
yes for this?
"I INTERRUPT AND INTRUDE ON OTHERS."
"I interrupt chime-in, or intrude into other people's conversation."
I'm gonna go ahead and no. I've already answered this I don't do that. That's bullshit. That's rude. That's rude!
I've got manners that's rude what am I? Am I totally ADHD?
"Your total score for hyperactivity and impulsivity is five out of nine."
"Threshold is five the predominantly combined subtype of ADHD."
Okay, what does that mean?
"Since you scored a five or more in part one, this suggests you may have what is called predominantly combined"
"Subtype of ADHD this is the most common type of ADHD."
I don't know what that means
But it sounds like it's a bunch of bullshit, but this test online must be loong!
So there goes my fate. I have ADHD, what a revelation
this is I got to tell my doctor who diagnosed me for ADHD that I have ADHD according to the thing on the internet.
But either way, this is a bullshit test online.
But actually the questions are kind of interesting even though they seem pretty broad in their application.
So for those of you who have ADHD out there just know it's okay. You're going to get through life just fine
no matter what you do. I've had ADHD on medication and off. I'm able to concentrate more when I'm on it. I take Adderall and
when I'm off it. I get a little zany, but you know give and take it is what it is,
it doesn't impede me on my normal day to day life.
But it does help me work when I need to get down and work.
SO, that is all for this video.
Thank you, everybody who joined me on this quiz. How did you do? What do you have?
I'll put a link into this test in the description below, but don't take it as truth.
It is just a guide. So thank you again and as always I will see you in the next video buh-bye!